في صوره مختلفه في الجانب الاخر ايضا وصلت
طائره اغاثيه سعوديه كما يبدو نحن حاولنا
التواجد في داخل ساحه المطار
نعم نحن في مطار غازي عنتاب حاولنا
التواجد في داخل هذه الساحه لانه تم المنع
النظره لكثره الطائرات ونظرا ايضا وصول
بعض الطائرات الاخرى الاغاثيه الى مطار
غازي عنتاب وهيام ربما المرحله الاهم في
هذه اللحظه تحدث عن السلطات التركيه التي
تقول بانه في هذه اللحظه ولحظه نقل
المساعدات الانسانيه الاغاثيه بشكل مباشر
والمطارات الى الداخل المناطق المتضرره هي
لحظه مهمه جدا فبالتالي انقلب مطار غازي
عنتاب الى خليه نحل تعمل فيها كافه
المنظمات الدوليه
لنقل هذه المساعدات بشكل مباشر استقبالها
اذا كان ربما هنالك من كثره هذه المساعدات
فاطمه وتواجدها
يحدث احيان تاخير في بعض الرحلات الاغاثيه
واحيان اخرى يتم تسريع بعض العمل في داخل
هذا المجمع
او المكتب في داخل هذا المطار الذي بدا
باستقباله في الحقيقه كنا معكم قبل قليل
في اماكن متفرقه من غازي عنتابو في اماكن
تواجد
المباني المهدده تصل الى مطار غازي عنتاب
والتي تقول انها كثيره هل هي فقط لغازي
عنتاب اما يتم ام يتم نقلها للمناطق
المنكوبه الاخرى
هي تبدا من هنا من مطار غازي عنتاب وتنتقل
الى مناطق مختلفه
هي اكثر حاجه سواء كان في غازي عنتاب او
في المناطق الاخرى التي
سيتم توزيع هذه المساعدات اليكم تشاهدين
في الصوره ربما هنالك بعض
المسؤولين السعوديين في الدفاع المدني
الذي يبدا بعمليه تسجيل بعض
المعلومات الاخيره
للدخول هذه المساعدات بالاضافه الى
مساعدات اخرى لعدد كبير منظمات تتحدث عن
66 منظمه وهيئه عامله تعمل في مساعده
وايصال هذه المساعدات وكما تشاهدين في
الصوره نحن اتينا في المطار لننقل الصوره
ونستطلع العمل الجاري في نقل هذه
المساعدات ربما هنالك بعض
الاعمال التي ستتم فبالتالي يطلبون منا
ايقاف
هذا المباشر